are you [ __ ] crazy you know bad your
traditional TV ad is no matter how
awesome you are
you got your perspective I would run
Facebook and LinkedIn ads and make
contextual creative to the data that
shows me who the historic customers you
tend to get are and I would run the ads
against those demographics and
psychographics
and I would make 43 different pieces of
video starting you or somebody else that
went to bring them value so that we
built awareness are you [ __ ] crazy
do you know bad your traditional TV ad
is no matter how awesome you are by
building a brand digger they are in the
only way you if that gets to the scale
that it could listen to the words if
that gets the scale that it could in 15
years the only thing that's left is
brand they have to say Alexa get me can
you get me digger you know because if
they say give me a personal you know
give me a lawyer give me or whatever a
trainer a milkshake
whatever they're going they're gonna
have and that is gonna play out
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah if you if you by taking 20 to 40%
of that money and putting it 100% into
something like Facebook against your
core demo fit you know 45 to 90 that
still translates there and then by
teaming up with your team and others to
take 5% and start the beginning of that
next generation which is not gonna come
you're not going to do well at first or
maybe even at all on Instagram at first
but it's just starting to build the
awareness but I will promise you this
sir and this is universal
there is no radio and billboard perfect
execution that Trump's perfect Facebook
execution for who you're trying to reach
here's why on common sense that
billboard is vanilla the fact that you
can make a reference to jaylen Hertz
transferring to Oklahoma to Oklahoma you
know like you could do all sorts of [ __ ]
you can make 8,000 billboards that
matter to 8,000 different psychographic
and demographic Alabama's got a lot of
micro personalities genders races age
groups you're gonna make it you know why
the Andy Warhol Superbowl commercial
last year that Burger King did missed
the mark because nobody under 40 [ __ ]
knew what the [ __ ] was going on when you
sell vanilla then that was a popular
flavor but when you sell vanilla you
miss a lot of customers and what you're
doing is sheer penetration and you're no
dummy
billboards can't work as well as they
did ten years ago
every passengers looking down at their
phone I'd rather them see your pretty
face
[Music]
I get the sense that attorneys are not
there dear customers of your corporate
attorney your customers not around
what's another way to scale for sharing
mighty networks I think it's less about
putting them into a funnel that's a
technical infrastructure and it's more
about taking the thought of community
layering it up so for example one thing
that I think of people are very naive up
is how digital is actually the gateway
to real life so I think if you put out
great content on LinkedIn for example
which these customers are on and you're
bringing value to them from their
perspective not yours
and then the 19th posts you put in at
you know where the 900th is hey I'm
actually going to be putting together a
dinner where we're gonna drink some good
wine and just talk about business or
this industry or corporate law and the
first eight people to RSVP I'll see you
in a private room in the restaurant I
think what when you want to get to the
top the way to put them into a Facebook
group is to give them good wine in a
private room in a restaurant that you
use the digital content to create the
RSVP
so how much time in each day we're going
up the phone and trying to do that with
my husband going down how much time put
on is it a bad time used to do a lot and
we you actually learn from it you
consciously focus the learning yes fully
that oh well I spent I spend I spend
100% of my time I'm watching people
react to things not to the actual thing
100% but I also and what de rock would
tell you is you know my copy skill like
I know what people want because I'm
listening first for all my talking and
all my interrupting the question and all
this
I'm listening at all times thus I have a
better sense I just know what resonates
because I'm so and don't forget and you
know this this is now [ __ ] 37 years
of like I don't you know this is this is
talent you know like I've had to come to
realize I'm like alright in business in
entrepreneurship and communication no
different than than singing and in
sports there is natural talent the
reason I set up the conversation around
lemonade and baseball cards I've been
doing this for so long it's why I was
such an atrocious student it was so
black and white to me that I couldn't
even give I couldn't even pander to
societal norms of the 80s to even
appease my poor mother who would punish
me so bad every report card because I
wanted that every second in the
classroom to figure out why did they
laugh when I disrupted that why is
everybody wearing those sneak I mean
like it's cry I literally just said
something that I've never started nobody
rocks never heard this Isis sit in class
and fundamentally analyze everything
people wore without even knowing why I
was doing that and so that's it
thinking about how to monetize that I
spend note I spend notes active I'm a
little bit unusual and you may note I
think you know this I have a separate
business that doesn't monetize my
audience thus I spend no time my great
secret compared to all the other
personalities is is none of the
important finances cover 0 0 because the
frameworks already been created I I just
know there's some trickle-down but 0
thought into it I don't know you know
it's just not the way I think I build
other businesses to make sure I don't
have to rely on any conversion from it
hi you can ask you it when we sell a
t-shirt for fun to learn like I'll do on
my text messaging platform or if it's
those sneakers or the wine i weirdly
like better when it doesn't do well yes
yes but but again the economics are so
my newton compare sale yes which but
really that [ __ ] matters that changes
the entire intent paradigm
[Music]
when to engage and whatnot it's a great
question yes there is no formula I think
you're actually I actually think you've
got it down because I do the same I just
think it comes down to timing and
serendipity sometimes you just got 15
minutes and you know you're sometimes
when there's something when there's a
lot of things going bad around me I've
got some fires I got some issues my
grandma passed away last you know this
last summer and you know when she was
not you know like life life right the
Jets are only three I'm on tilt you know
you know sometimes I'm not just in the
mood to know I'm gonna have to spend 15
minutes maybe going back and forth to
try to write other times I'm bored feel
fresh I got eight minutes cuz something
got canceled and I'm like I'm gonna get
in there I wouldn't over judge yourself
there is no proper answer I think it's
predicated on your current mindset to be
able to be the bigger person people lose
because they go into a debate or a
conversation but they're not emotionally
balanced which allows them to get
triggered which makes them overreact
which changes the context of the actual
merit of the conversation which [ __ ]
up the whole thing
aka America
[Music]
you're never gonna go when you go oh
we're gonna spend 30,000 a month with
business agencies to help us with our
Facebook's that's right I think in a
small scale in-house is a great way to
go I don't even think you can steal
somebody my belief is that everybody I'm
looking at right now should take the
at-bat to try to figure it out
themselves because it's that important
that was a point I made about balancing
your checkbook like to me communications
is oxygen no different than actually
understanding how to handle cash flow I
really believe that I believe it's
become that and singularly important I
really believe that